so
today i want to continue our discussion
of
amino acid metabolism and before we do
that i just want to come back for a few
minutes
and revisit the urea cycle and
the krebs bicycle that we discussed at
the very end of the last lecture
i only want to do that because it a lot
going on with this cycle
it can appear on the surface to be
confusing the
molecules are hard to draw and so i just
wanted to draw it
neatly here for you one last time and go
through
it um you know again and so
remember if we start from the amino acid
arginine
arginine can be converted into the
non-proteinogenic amino acid ornithine
and in the process release urea
that ornithine can then be in the
mitochondria converted to
citrulline another non-proteinogenic
amino acid
by picking up a carbon and a nitrogen
from
this molecule carbomolyl phosphate
which is generated from co2 slash
bicarbonate
as well as ammonia and
two phosphorylations with atp to get
carbonyl phosphate
that's added to ornithine to get
citrulline that citrulline can then
combine with the amino acid aspartate to
give this molecule
arginosuccinate so arginine plus a
succinate on it
and then loss of fumarate
leaves you with arginine that fumarate
can of course go through the tca cycle
to regenerate malate
oxaloacetate ultimately pick up
nitrogen on oxaloacetate is that alpha
keto acid
is transaminated to aspartate of course
getting that
nitrogen from glutamate to alpha
ketoglutarate
and glutamate of course can get its
nitrogen either by transamination
with another um uh amino acid to an
alpha-keto acid
converting alpha-ketoglutarate to
glutamate or
glutamate can be generated by this redox
reaction where it picks up on ammonia
by the enzyme glutamate dehydrogenase
so you'll notice in this cycle that
ultimately the arginine the urea group
what is released as urea from arginine
comes from
the carbomyl phosphate so that's one of
these nitrogens
that was picked up in the synthesis of
carbonyl phosphate
and the other one comes from aspartate
which of course can come from ammonia
via
glutamate dehydrogenase and
transamination
or from transamination from nitrogen
picked up from any other
amino acid to ultimately end up on
aspartate
you'll notice that there's redox balance
across this
whole cycle and so there's a
nad that's required to reconvert the
malate oxaloacetate to run this half of
the reaction
but of course if we pick up an ammonia
we also
have a redox reaction involved in the
glutamate dehydrogenase reaction
you'll see that atp is also
quite a bit of atp is needed you need
two atp to generate each carbonyl
phosphate as well as
two atp equivalents to generate
arginosuccinate
because remember if you go back to your
notes from last time you'll see that atp
to amp
plus pyrophosphate was part of the
citrulline and aspartate generating
arginosuccinate reaction and the last
thing is that
co2 is required to run the urea cycle
that's where the carbon and urea comes
from
and that co2 is of course picked up in
the generation
of carbonyl phosphate now
i think sometimes we can fall into the
you know misconception when we talk
about these that all cells generate urea
that's not true
so remember different organisms use
different strategies to excrete
nitrogen so in us as humans the liver
and the kidney would run the urea cycle
as i've drawn it here
as a way to ultimately produce urea that
gets excreted
in the blood i mean sorry in in the
urine whereas most
tissues in our body would simply ship
off excess nitrogen from the catabolism
of amino acids
to the liver and the kidney by
generating either glutamate or glutamine
and the reactions that we talked about
last time and then those organs would
deal
with use the real cycle to produce urea
and get rid of
excess nitrogen but of course there's
other animals that will use
other strategies secreted as ammonia
directly
or produce the purine uric acid which of
course we'll talk about
um next time how one can
interconnect all this amino acid
nitrogen metabolism with
nucleic acid nitrogen metabolism
i just want to re-stress that this
glutamate
dehydrogenase reaction is a really
key reaction that is necessary to get
nitrogen
in and out of the system and
once you get nitrogen in and out of the
system
you can then use these transamination
reactions
to move nitrogens around between amino
acids and alpha keto acids
using pyridoxal phosphate as we
discussed last time
this is shown up above also as
the bicycle reaction and again
just stresses that you sort of are
running the urea cycle on the right
this other tca modified tca cycle if you
will on the left
and ultimately illustrates how you pick
up those
nitrogens and um co2 to to
generate urea
but of course if we're going to talk
about how you would make
amino acids which is really the topic of
today how you
break down and synthesize the carbon
skeletons of different amino acids
well obviously here's arginine
metabolism you can imagine that you
could use the same reactions to
produce or break down arginine and that
is what happens
but i also want to talk about the
remaining amino acids and the remaining
amino acids
it's really about how do we deal with
the carbon skeleton the alpha keto acids
and of course these are linked via this
pyridoxal phosphate driven
transamination reactions
now i don't have time to
in this course to go through how each
amino acid carbon skeleton
is produced and broken down we'll
discuss
some major themes however if i don't
cover your favorite amino acid because
of course
all people should have a favorite amino
acid
you can look up the pathways to make it
or break it down
and i promise that if you paid attention
through the whole class you have the
skills to
understand that particular pathway even
if we don't
study it in class so
i want to remind you that in general for
amino acid catabolism
and this is in general of course there
are exceptions arginine
would behave as i just described for the
urea cycle but for most amino acids
you start
with transamination
okay so what does that give you that
gives the nitrogen
to alpha-ketoglutarate to generate
glutamate okay and so that glutamate can
then
be shipped off to generate ammonia if
you're a fish generate your urea if
you're
a human etc okay and
what does that leave you with that
leaves you with um
a alpha keto acid
related to the amino acid that can then
be oxidized
to co2 using various pathways
burn it and get energy just like we've
described
for carbohydrates and fatty acids or of
course
you know in some cases produce
glucose or some other molecule that can
then be used to support
gluconeogenesis in the liver keep
glucose high in our blood
okay and so that's generally
how most amino acids are catabolized
it's very clear how this works if we
start with some of the
more obvious ones so we talked last time
about how
alanine the amino acid is related
so transamination get the alpha keto
acid that alpha keto acid is pyruvate
aspartate amino acid
undergoes transamination the alpha-keto
acid is oxaloacetate
glutamate undergoes transamination
alpha-keto acid is alpha-ketoglutarate
it's very clear how
all of these can end up in the tca cycle
or gluconeogenesis
for the cell to either oxidize for
for energy or to produce something
like glucose that can be used elsewhere
now of course there's other amino acids
out there that we've already talked
about so remember asparagine
very similar to aspartate glutamine
similar to glutamate so those were the
ammonia group on the side chain we can
simply remove those should be clear how
to um
then get those into the tca cycle or
gluconeogenesis a little
bit of metabolic trivia humans we
actually don't have an enzyme to break
down asparagine
other organisms do and then the other
one that we alluded to last time was
proline
which is cyclized
and and oxidized glutamate
and so i'll just illustrate here quickly
how proline can be metabolized
just so you can see this
so here's the amino acid
proline okay and so proline
to show you if we do oxidation of this
carbon nitrogen bond so
that utilizes he's an electron acceptor
that electron acceptor happens to be fad
being reduced to fadh2 okay that
generates
this molecule we can then add water
across
that double bond
now we can open up the ring
like this
okay so just opened up the ring
now i'm going to oxidize this
aldehyde to the acid so if i do that
something else has to be reduced that
something else
can be nad plus or nadp
plus depending on
the enzyme there's enzymes that use
either nad or nadp
to make nadp h or nadh
respectively and then what i'm left with
is
this amino acid glutamate
and so that's how i turn proline into
glutamate
to additional um oxidation steps
um generating fadh2 and nadh or nadph
and so that's how you would derive
energy from the catabolism of
proline by feeding it into glutamate
which can then of course be
transaminated off a ketoglutarate and
the rest of the carbon enter
the tca cycle okay
so that covers one two three four five
six
amino acids seven if you count arginine
that we
talked about the euthuria cycle that
leaves 13
additional amino acids many of them
are first transaminated to the alpha
keto acid
and then ultimately use the carbon
skeleton
can be used to generate a um another
intermediate that's either involved in
the tca cycle
or glycolysis and shown here on the
slide is basically just a figure from a
textbook that
contains all of the various um
all of the 20 amino acids from protein
and what they generate
um either in the tca cycle or um
or up here so you can see here the sun
make oxaloacetate fumarate sectional coa
alpha ketoglutarate acetyl coa pyruvate
acetoacetate
which of course as we saw last time can
be used to generate
two stokoa or be used to generate the
ketone body beta hydroxy butyrate
now obviously if you can generate
any of these things we already know the
pathways about how you can
oxidize them or in some cases how you
can turn them
into glucose but now i want to return to
this
idea that we've come to a bunch of
different times
that really comes down to this fact of
what we talked about with the tca cycle
how the tca cycle can't net do
anaplerosis
from two carbon units that is you can't
turn acetyl co
acetyl coa or acetoacetate because
that's just two acetyl coa molecules
into anything that can generate glucose
right that's we don't have the glaxolate
cycle
organisms that have the glaxology cycle
can do this but we as humans
cannot do that now many of our
amino acids can be used to produce
you know things like fumarate suctional
coax aloe acetate all right all of that
stuff
can easily be turned into glucose and so
if we starve ourselves or go on a
low carbohydrate diet well what happens
is our liver will break down
amino acids and use those amino acids to
make glucose
but we can only make glucose from amino
acids if those amino acids
are broken down into something that's
not acetyl coa
or acetyl acetate because we don't have
a glyoxylate
cycle all right just remember i
mentioned a couple lectures ago when we
talked about the ketogenic diet
a true ketogenic diet isn't just low
carbohydrates it's also low protein
because your liver will
turn that protein back into glucose
and so if you really want to be ketotic
you have to
limit both glucose and
both sugars and proteins because
fat of course will only be broken into
two carbon units and you can't turn
those into glucose so you instead turn
them into
ketones all right now
not all amino acids skeletons though
can be used to make something that can
generate glucose
some can only make stuff acetyl coa
acetoacetate
that can be used to generate um ketones
and so this defines another way to
classify amino acids
as so-called glucogenic amino acids
or ketogenic
amino acids
and this is a direct consequence of what
those amino acid carbon skeletons
are broken into and so a glucogen
glucogenic amino acid
is really any amino acid
where product
of breakdown
is greater than two carbons that is
not acetyl
coa all right whereas a ketogenic
amino acid is an amino acid
where
product of breakdown
is acetyl coa
and i should mention or
acetoacetate
because acetoacetate as we saw
is two acetyl
coase okay so acetyl coa acetoacetate
can be turned into the ketone body beta
hydroxybutyrate
okay an alternative fuel for the brain
if you break down an amino acid and all
you get is acetyl coa or acetoacetate
you can't turn that
um carbon skeleton back into glucose
therefore it's a ketogenic amino acid
all other amino acids that generate
oxaloacetate
succinyl coa whatever something greater
than
two carbons not acetyl coa it can then
be turned into glucose
therefore it's a glucogenic um
amino acids now if we come back over
here
to our slide and you look at the various
amino acids
most of the amino acids are turned into
something
that can be turned into glucose and so
most
amino acids are so-called glucogenic
however there's a few amino acids that
are
ketogenic and there's some amino acids
that are both glucogenic
and ketogenic and so if you look here
through the slide
what you'll find is that tyrosine and
isoleucine so there's isoleucine
here's tyrosine so they're turned into
ketones
but they can also be here's tyrosine
here's isoleucine
can also be turned into something that
can be used to make glucose and so
they're referred to as both glucogenic
and ketogenic all right now
as i said before we don't have time to
go through how to break down
all of the amino acids okay but i will
take you through how you break down
the three branched chain amino acids
and i will do that because first of all
it will illustrate that you already know
a lot about metabolism
you'll see that how these are broken
down is just variations on
pathways that we've already discussed
and so it really drives home the fact
that
the complexity of metabolism is really
just nature
repurposing relatively few reactions
over and over and over again
in a way that ultimately builds
complexity and diversity
but in the end is actually quite quite
consistent across the whole thing
um and you'll also see examples of how
amino acid skeleton breakdown can end up
either as glucagon
glucogenic or ketogenic and that's
because
of the various branched chain amino
acids so there's of course
leucine valine and
isoleucine okay so those are the
three branch chain amino acids you'll
see
that leucine is ketogenic
valine is glucogenic
and isoleucine as i just said
is both ketogenic
and glucogenic
okay so three very related amino acids
in genetic terms very conservative
substitutions within a protein
okay very
related structures however the way
they're broken down
in the case of leucine generates only
things that are ketogenic
valine generates things that are
glucogenic and isoleucine generates both
and so um we'll go through
each of these and see how that happens
all right
so let's start with leucine
okay so leucine is a as i said above is
a ketogenic
amino acid all right and so leucine
like many amino acids starts breakdown
by transamination so this transamination
will of course take the nitrogen from
leucine
alpha an alpha-keto acid the
alpha-ketoglutarate
generate glutamate as well as the
alpha-keto acid of leucine which just to
remind you what leucine looks like
looks like this
okay so this is the side chain over here
of leucine
here's the alpha keto acid related to
leucine if i
take this alpha keto group turn it into
an amino group that's leucine
so this is the alpha keto acid related
to
leucine all right so the next step
of leucine breakdown involves
oxidative decarboxylation
of this alpha keto acid okay so
if you remember we've seen this reaction
before we did it in
pyruvate to generate acetaldehyde and
ethanol
metabolism we did it in what we did
alpha decarboxylation there
and then we did oxidative alpha
decarboxylation when we turned pyruvate
into acetyl-coa and we turned
alpha-ketoglutarate into succinyl coa
well that exact reaction which we saw
with pyruvate dehydrogenase
as well as what we saw with
alpha-ketoglutarate dehydrogenase
generating acyl coa and succinyl coa is
what happens here
for the alpha-keto acids produced
from breakdown of leucine and other
branched chain amino acids
and so if you look back in your notes we
went through the mechanism of this in
detail
remember this involved addition of coa
loss of co2
it's an oxidation reaction
okay so remember the electrons needed to
go somewhere
and so they ended up going to nadh so
that's oxidized
nad plus is reduced to nadh and remember
this involved that mini electron
transport chain
with fad lipoic acid
and tpp plus
okay and in the end that releases the
co2
and you end up with this
branch chain acyl coa
all right so same reaction as pdh
alpha ketoglutarate dehydrogenase just
like those two reactions remember that
had an e1 an e2 and an e3 subunit
so this actually uses the exact same e2
and e3 subunit as those reactions
the e1 subunit is of course different
because it's unique to the
um to the branch chain amino acids
whereas in pyruvate dehydrogenase would
be unique to pyruvate and alpha
ketoglutarate dehydrogenase unique to
alpha-ketoglutarate
in this case this enzyme is called bckdh
for branch chain keto acid dehydrogenase
and allows the oxidative decarboxylation
to generate this branch chain acyl
coa now this branched chain acyl coa
looks a lot like a fatty acid and in
fact it's metabolized very much
like we would do fatty acid oxidation so
what's the first step in
beta oxidation of fatty acids well we
would introduce a double bond here
and so that's exactly what happens
next so this would be
a membrane-bound fad
containing enzyme part of the electron
transport chain
gonna oxidize that carbon-carbon bond
okay what does that generate
all right now if we're doing fatty acid
oxidation we of course add water across
that bond we'll do that in a minute
before that happens the next step though
is that
to facilitate ultimately breakdown of
this we're going to end up
adding a carboxyl group to the end of
the molecule
so if we're going to add co2 to the end
of the molecule how would we do that
well we've seen that reaction many times
before as well
so if we're going to add a co2 group
that's going to come from biotin okay
so the next enzyme would have
biotin in the active site that can pick
up
a co2 how does it pick up the co2
well it picks up the co2 via
bicarbonate plus
atp and that's going to go to
that's going to phosphorylate the
bicarbonate and then
when we transfer that phosphorylated
bicarbonate onto biotin
we'll release the pi then the co2 from
biotin
can be added to uh to carboxylate that
molecule just like we've saw
before with other carboxylation
reactions
and that will generate
this intermediate
all right this intermediate here okay so
no new chemistry you've seen all this
many times before now we're going to
continue with
what we would do is if we were breaking
this down uh
oxidizing it as a fatty acid and so now
we're going to add water across
that double bond
okay now we added water across that
double bond
and then now we're just going to
do this reaction which will generate
from this side of the molecule
and acetyl-coa
and if you look on the other side of the
molecule
what we are left with is
aceto
acetate
okay acetoacetate can be
broken down into
two
two acetyl coas if i break it in half
add coat to each one of them
by reactions i showed you before as well
or of course
we can reduce this ketone to the alcohol
and make the ketone body beta hydroxy
butyrate okay you can look that up from
the
end of the last lecture but in the end
this is how
one can break down the leucine skeleton
you get acetyl coa or acetyl acetate
can't generate glucose from any of those
molecules
as humans because we don't have a
glaxology cycle therefore
leucine is a ketogenic amino acid
all right valine let's look at valine so
valine
okay so valine is glucogenic
despite the fact that it's very similar
to leucine
and broken down in a way that's very
similar to leucine
so how do we break it down so first step
transamination nitrogen from valine to
alpha-ketoglutarate
generate glutamate and as well as the
branch chain alpha keto acid
that's related to valine
okay so that's the alpha keto acid
related to valine
one carbon shorter than side chain
one carbon shorter than leucine
just like we did with
leucine we're going to metabolize
the alpha keto acid with the branched
chain keto acid dehydrogenase same
reaction oxidative decarboxylation
here that releases
co2 adds coa reaction involves
also nad plus to nadh
requires lipoic acid tpp plus fad
just like what we described before i'm
not going to draw out all the pieces
of it again but we're going to end up
with the
the branch chain acyl coa
metabolize this branched chain acyl coa
as if it's a fatty acid
and so first step oxidize this
carbon-carbon bond
that electrons go to fad
make fadh2
okay this product
add water across
that double bond
okay water across that double bond
next if we oxidize
this alcohol twice so
oxidize it once we'll get the aldehyde
oxidize it again
we can get the carboxylic acid
and so oxidizing twice
means nad
plus times two and nadh
times two and now that becomes the acid
okay so same molecule but now this
alcohol
becomes an acid i drew it that way
on purpose if you look back in your
notes this
is methyl
malonyl
coa which we saw before in
our discussion of
odd chain fatty acid metabolism
and you'll remember that there was this
b12 dependent reaction
where i can basically swap the positions
of this proton and this
um uh thioester group
here this is not arrow pushing this is
this b12 dependent reaction that i
described
before where i can
rearrange methylmalonyl coa
to make
this molecule which is suctional coa
suctional coa oxidizing the tca cycle
generate atp but also can use it as a
substrate
anaplerosis for the tca cycle so it can
be used to generate glucose
and so that's why valine is a glucogenic
amino acid all right
last branch chain amino acid
is isoleucine
okay so isoleucine is both ketogenic
and glucogenic
okay so let's see how that happens
so if we start with isoleucine first we
undergo transamination
alpha alluterate to glutamate and you
get the
branch chain
alpha keto acid okay so that's
isoleucine
as an alpha-keto acid rather than an
amino acid
next step
do the alpha decarboxylation with
branch chain keto acid dehydrogenase
that removes that co2
oxidizes that carbon to the acid and
we end up with this
is branch chain acyl coa
all right same first steps as we saw
before metabolize that
as if it's a fatty acid
okay so oxidize that carbon-carbon bond
add water across
the double bond
okay get this intermediate all right
now oxidize this
alcohol to the ketone
electrons go to nad plus
which is reduced to nadh
okay now we can use co-a
to
take off this end of the molecule here
which is acetyl-coa
hence ketogenic
the remainder of the molecule
is this
three carbon acyl coa
we saw this from odd chain fatty acid
metabolism this is
propionil coe
okay remember to deal with that
we can add co2
okay so that of course requires
biotin and atp
okay so remember we add co2 to this
molecule
that gives us methyl not going to draw
it all out for the sake of time
but that gives us methyl malonyl
coa okay methylmalonyl coa
shown up there so it's adding co2 to
this molecule
and then we can do the vitamin
b12
rearrangement to get succinyl coa
and so that can be turned into glucose
and so
it generates an acetyl coa and suctional
coa isoleucine is both
glucogenic and ketogenic all right
and so a little tedious to go through
how you break down all three of those
branched chain amino acids
but it really illustrates that it's just
variations on the same chemistry that
we've seen before with fatty acid
metabolism
tca cycle reactions that ultimately
generate intermediates that can be fed
into the tca cycle
oxidized further to co2 generate
atp generate nadh electron transport
chain oxidative phosphorylation
supply the cell with energy to do
various kinds of work
or can be turned into a ketone
if you're a human and you start with
acetyl in which you get is acetyl coa or
acetoacetate
or even into glucose if you start with a
um something like succinyl coa that can
be turned
back into glucose by the liver defining
the difference between the glucogenic
and the ketogenic
amino acids all right
now going through branch chain amino
acid metabolism
also allows transition
into a discussion of another topic
which are the so-called
inborn
errors of metabolism
so what's an inborn error of metabolism
well
sometimes individuals are born
that have deficiencies in enzymes
that are necessary to carry out some
function
of metabolism some aspect of the
biochemistry
we've been learning about now you can
imagine that
some of these genetic deficiencies if
it's somewhere
smack in the middle of central carbon
metabolism and you can't generate energy
is not going to be compatible with life
but it turns out that some of them are
quite compatible with life
like deficiency in branch
chain keto acid dehydrogenase so
b c k d h
deficiency is something that
children are sometimes born with and
this deficiency
results in a disorder called
maple syrup urine disease
so it's called maple syrup urine disease
because
the urine smells like maple syrup all
right but effectively
what this is is this is a disorder where
there's a deficiency in the activity of
branched chain keto acid dehydrogenase
that means the cells can't break down
branch chain amino acids they end up
generating
some otherwise side toxic product
some of it ends up in the urine smells
like maple syrup um
but it also can result in damage to the
cns
and um and uh
problems with um you know thinking
mental retardation
etc and so can be quite
devastating to have loss of this enzyme
which prevents you
from breaking down branch chain amino
acids
a so-called inborn error of metabolism
now this is a relatively rare disease
all of these are but if you go to
medical school
these are questions because they lend
themselves to questions
that often short up on various board
type
exams and so it's good to know that
deficiencies of some of these enzymes
can result
in um you know diseases so maple syrup
urine disease
caused by an inability to break down
branched chain amino acids
because you're deficient in the enzyme
branch chain amino acid
or branch chain keto acid dehydrogenase
which catalyzes the step i showed you up
there
in in breakdown of all three branched
chain amino acids
by no means is this the only one often
these are associated
with um amino acid breakdown
and so two of the other more common all
of these are very rare but
relatively more common ones is a disease
called alkaptonuria
so what's alcaptanuria well that's
missing an enzyme
so enzyme deficiency
in
tryptophan metabolism
okay and another one is
fennel
ketonuria which is an enzyme
deficiency in
phenylalanine metabolism
okay branch chain amino acids are very
common
all right but tryptophan phenylalanine
two of the more rare amino acids
it turns out these are two of the amino
acid breakdown deficiencies that
have less severe phenotypes
and so they're somewhat
you know more people walking around with
those
conditions if any of you
have had children or someday when you
have children
what will happen is is that you will
notice that when babies are born
one of the first things that's done with
infants is they have a blood test send
out they do a little
heel stick collect some blood and send
it to the state lab
where they test for various inborn
errors of metabolism
what they're looking for is things like
phenylketonuria
maple syrup urine disease etc why do
they want to find these things well it's
because
if you have too much of the product too
much phenylalanine too much tryptophan
too much branched chain amino acid
and you can't break them down it's not
the lack of the ability to break them
down that's necessarily the problem the
problem is is that the inability to
break them down
leads to overwhelming a system building
up of toxic intermediates that damage
the brain
and so by doing these newborn screening
panels
it's greatly enhanced the management of
these things because often you can
control
the symptoms by dietary intervention
simply limiting
the phenylalanine or the branch chain
amino acid or the
tryptophan intake in the diet is a
treatment for these diseases
and so therefore if you know about them
early
limiting exposure to those things limits
the breakth
up the the exposure to the toxic
breakdown products that can't be
metabolized because of the deficiency
and therefore limits the effects
on the brain if you drink diet soda
and you look at the side of your diet
soda can
what's written on the side of it is
phenylketonurics
contains phenylalanine why is that
written there well
because if you happen to be a
phenylketonuric you shouldn't
dr drink diet soda why
because the artificial sweetener in
there contains phenylalanine
and so this will give you a big dose of
phenylalanine and if you can't break
down phenylalanine that's a problem so
it's a warning to
the people in the population who happen
to have phenylketonuria
not to drink diet soda okay
all right now i want to say a few other
things
about amino acid metabolism
only because these things will come
up for you as you
go through other aspects of biology
and that is that amino acids are
very versatile starting points to build
all kinds of hormones and
neurotransmitters and bioactive
molecules
so i know some people some of the mit
students in the class are course nine
that's uh um the
brain and cognitive science okay classes
you take you'll learn a lot about
different neurotransmitters well
one of the canonical neurotransmitters
is an amino acid itself it's the amino
acid
glutamate okay so obviously that's
important for the brain to work
but what are the other neurotransmitters
well there's things like dopamine
epinephrine
norepinephrine
these are all bioactive molecules have
to come from somewhere
well it turns out all of these
ultimately come from the metabolism
of tyrosine which of course
can also come from the metabolism of
phenylalanine
and so don't have time to go into it but
you can look up the pathways to generate
these various neurotransmitters from
tyrosine
um if you're interested all right
what's the other big neurotransmitter
well it's acetyl
choline okay
what's acetylcholine well let's break it
down well it's
an acetyl group so that comes from
acetyl-coa
and choline and what's choline well
choline
comes from ultimately as i
showed you alluded to before ethanol
amine
and ethanolamine comes from serine
we'll come back to this later and so
serine metabolism as well as acetyl coa
is how you get
acetylcholine it's also choline for the
phospholipids and ethanol amine for the
phospholipids
you're not into the brain but into other
aspects of physiology
so thyroid hormone
very common thing that many people need
replacement of very important to manage
physiology in our body
thyroid hormone also comes from
tyrosine okay melanin
the pigment that makes our skin
different shades okay melanin the skin
pigment it
is basically produced from dopamine are
actually a
dopamine metabolite so dopamine
precursor
which comes from tyrosine
as well and so if you're interested in
any of these particular
molecules of course you can look up in
the book and you'll see how they're made
and
i promise you have the ability to
understand it it's repurposing
some reactions that we've already seen
there's some unique
ones in there like melanin synthesis is
actually parts of it are non-enzymatic
even
but this i like to mention this because
obviously we don't have time to study
and discuss the entire complexity of the
metabolic map
but really you understand the basics the
central parts of it
and it's the same reactions repurposed
out in different directions that allows
this complexity in this diversity of
metabolism making all of these different
biomolecules that are necessary for the
cells to do things
and of course you can go look these up
if you're interested in
any of them specifically and regardless
you should have some appreciation of how
these things all
interconnect with the other pathways
that we've
talked about all right
all right so now i want to turn to
amino acid synthesis and say
a few words about how amino acids
are built so of course
we've covered some of these already and
as a very general statement many of them
are made by
transamination so first you build the
alpha keto acid
and then you transaminate that alpha
keto acid from
glutamate to generate the amino acid
now of course the pathways that you use
to make
amino acids are not the same as the
pathways that use to break down amino
acids
so again if you paid attention for the
entire course it should be clear
for both thermodynamic energetic reasons
that you can't have the same pathways to
build and break stuff down
because all pathways delta g has to be
less than zero
so we saw this with glucose and fatty
acids right we can repurpose some steps
can be the same
but the ones that allow the energetic
driving
have to be different because you have to
couple
one direction to energy consumption and
the
other one could be spontaneous if it
releases energy and you have to have
pathways that can work
in either direction all right but
in general if you can build an alpha
keto acid
like oxaloacetic acid or
alpha-ketoglutarate
or pyruvate well obviously we can
transaminate all of these things to get
the amino acid
soft literate to glutamate it can also
be from glutamate dehydrogenase that's
how you can get new nitrogen into the
system
and that way we can generate aspartate
glutamate and alanine
turn aspartate into asparagine
asparagine by adding the ammonia to it
that'd be a very similar reaction to
glutamine glutamate into glutamine
that's
glutamate synthase asparagine synthase
same mechanism described glutamate
synthase last time to make glutamine
and of course proline as i showed you
earlier
is cyclized and in this case um
oxidized uh or sorry cyclized and
reduced
um glutamate all right and then
um so that's six of the amino acids we
covered
um arginine earlier that's seven
and so 13 other amino acids
here's another figure from a book just
showing the
starting material to make all of the
various
um amino acids obviously we know how to
make oxaloacetate
phosphoenolpyruvate erythros4 phosphate
pyruvate
ribose 5-phosphate 3-phosphoglycerate
now for ketoglutarate
and so generation of those by the
pathways we've already talked about
then allows those molecules to be
shunted into pathways to generate
all of the various amino acids
now i want to reiterate humans we can't
make all 20 amino acids
okay animals can't do that many
organisms of course can
we lost the ability to make nine of our
amino acids
and in fact if you count the two
conditional ones really 11
of our amino acids even though we can
turn phenylalanine into tyrosine
we still need a source of phenylalanine
to do so
and so each of these 9 or 11 depending
on how you count it essential amino
acids
must be eaten in the diet okay so there
are obviously pathways to do them we
just don't have the enzymes and humans
to do it
um and then the other ones we do
retain you can obviously look up the
pathway that's used by whatever organism
to make your
favorite amino acid today what i want to
discuss is how we will make
today i want to discuss how we will make
serine and glycine because
it turns out serine and glycine
metabolism
play a key role in other pathways
including nucleotide synthesis which we
will cover
in the next lecture all right
serine glycine metabolism also is a way
to make one carbon units that are more
reduced
than co2 and these will be critical for
one carbon
transfer reactions that you'll encounter
throughout
other aspects of biology
okay so serine and glycine
very important amino acids all right
and so just to be clear about this so it
turns out serine
glycine metabolism important for
nucleotides in one carbon units we'll
see that a lot
but serine and glycine also used to make
phospholipid head groups
okay nucleotides one carbon units we're
going to talk about i want you to
appreciate
also need serine to make phospholipid
head groups
so what do i mean by that well of course
there's phosphatidyl
serine
obviously that's serine is the head
group and so serine
the amino acid is required for that but
also
used to generate ethanolamine
okay so what is ethanolamine
well again just to remind you of this
okay so here is the amino acid serine
okay so to generate ethanolamine
it's decarboxylation of
serine to do that so
loss of this co2 this is a reaction i
don't have time to go into you can look
it up it is another repurposing of
pyridoxal phosphate
and that generates this molecule
which is ethanolamine that ends up
head group on phosphatidylethanolamine
and if i want to turn it into choline
either for acetylcholine as a
neurotransmitter
or for phosphatidylcholine as a head
group
it's basically adding
three methyl groups
onto this nitrogen of ethanolamine
and so
those three methyl groups that's a
carbon that's more reduced
than co2 that's a so-called one carbon
unit
it turns out as you'll see those also
come
from serine all right last thing is
serine is necessary to make a
head groups for a class of lipids called
sphingolipids
there's a sphingosine
is another amino alcohol that
is generated from serine and ends up
being the head group for
sphingolipids especially if you're
interested
in the immune system or the brain these
end up being important molecules
and so you can look up how they're
related to serine but just appreciate
that
for now that they another important
downstream thing that's generated from
serine metabolism also illustrating
how amino acids can be very important to
generate lots of other
biomolecules okay so
how do we make serine
well we go over here you'll see that
serine is downstream of
3-phosphoglycerate from glycolysis
so what's 3-phosphoglycerate
okay here's three phosphoglycerate from
glycolysis
or product of rubisco if you like
all right so photosynthesis so there's
three possible glycerate
so if i oxidize this alcohol
to ketone electrons have to go
somewhere nad plus reduced to nadh
i get this intermediate
okay it's uh phospho hydroxy pyruvate so
pyruvate
with a phospho on it hydroxy pyruvate
um this molecule can undergo
a transamination reaction
so pick up nitrogen from glutamate
make the alpha keto acid take this alpha
keto acid and generate
phosphoserine okay the amino acid
that's phosphorylated phosphoserine and
then all i need to do
is de-phosphorylate it and i end up with
the amino acid
serum cool all right
to make glycine from serine so remember
glycine is one basically
the amino acid with no side chain on it
so i need to remove
this carbon and the alcohol all right so
just redraw serine this way
okay so that's redrawing searing
need to lose that group to get glycine
this is helped along by
paradoxical phosphate okay so
okay reminder this is pyrodoxyl
phosphate all right this
you
okay so this is exactly what we drew is
the first steps
in transamination okay except
if instead of basically
going like this i do this
to break
this carbon-carbon bond what do i
get well i release a one carbon
unit okay in this case
it's the one carbon unit as
formaldehyde
okay the one carbon aldehyde
formaldehyde
and generate
do
okay this intermediate
a
and so now i'm just exactly what
we showed before for
resolving the
transamination
and i am left with
glycine as well as i
regenerated pyridoxal phosphate for the
next
catalytic cycle of the enzyme
and so illustrates the flexibility of
paradoxical phosphate
in this case helping convert serine
into glycine and a one carbon unit
shown here as formaldehyde
now the enzyme that carries out this
reaction is an enzyme called
shmt
which stands for serine
hydroxy methyl
transferase okay
serine hydroxy methyl transferase and
it actually doesn't release the
formaldehyde
directly instead it transfers that
formaldehyde
to an important one carbon donor for
many
one carbon reactions um that
is called a folate species or folic acid
so remember if we transferred co2 in a
carboxylation reaction we used a
cofactor biotin
biotin's useful to transfer co2 but if
we're going to do something
like transfer the methyl groups shown up
there for choline synthesis
that's transferring carbon that's more
reduced than co2 and you don't use
biotin for that
instead you use um a cofactor called
folate
that's derived from the vitamin folic
acid okay so
folic acid very important
vitamin it's the primary thing that's
included in prenatal vitamins
why is that because deficiency in folic
acid
was shown a while back to cause um
neural tube defects so developmental
defects
where the neural tube does not close
this leads to things like spina bifida
one of the real successes of public
health intervention
was the recognition of this and
fortifying various cereals
with folic acid and doing so has greatly
reduced the incidence of these birth
defects involving
folate deficiency folate deficiency is
also a common cause of anemia and so
folic acid is a vitamin that lots of
people take for that reason
um and in fact folic acid also very
important in the
history of cancer treatment and if you
want to learn more about that
take 7 45 which is offered
in the fall all right
so folic acid is a complex
molecule that is converted in cells
to
a molecule called thf which stands for
tetrahydrofolate
okay so i'll draw out folic acid for you
and tetrahydrofolate
a
a
okay so this here is
folic acid the folic acid molecule is
tetrahydrofolate
it is has a peptide bond here
to a glutamate molecule and it's
actually a polyglutamate
tail that is there to trap it in cells
it's this central part of the molecule
here
that actually carries the one carbon
unit
and so the way that the nitrogens are
numbered this is nitrogen five
this is nitrogen 10 that will be
important in a minute
but it's really this sort of
central part here of the molecule that i
will draw
over and over again as the one carbon
unit carrying species
to show how this works it's easier if i
start off by showing
how it can pick up a more oxidized
one carbon unit so the one carbon
carboxylic acid
is this that's formate okay and so if i
phosphorylate
formic acid
okay this formic acid can then be picked
up by the
okay so here's the that
carrying part of the one carbon the box
part of of tetrahydrofolate and so
this can pick up
formic acid like this
okay so that gives us this molecule
which is called
n10 formal
tetrahydrofolate thf
i can create a ring
out of this molecule
oops
this
okay and if i remove water from this
ring
redraw it like this
h
okay this is called n5
and 10
methenol thf
and
if i
reduce that molecule
here's nadph so
hydride ion
okay then i end up with this molecule
which is n5
and 10.
methylene
thf and if i further
reduce this molecule
okay then i end up with
this molecule which is n5
methyl thf
appears incredibly complex
what's going on here but i went through
this because what i want you to realize
is that each of these species are simply
tetrahydrofolate carrying a one carbon
unit
in a different oxidation state okay
so this n10 formal thf
is carrying formic acid the one carbon
acid i can reduce it to
n5n10 methylene thf that's carrying the
one carbon aldehyde
formaldehyde or i could reduce it
further
this is carrying the one carbon um
methyl group as n5 methyl
thf and it turns out that this allows a
lot of flexibility
in carrying out one carbon reactions
here
is a same thing written from
a textbook the direction the order is
shown a little bit differently the
molecules are rotated
and it includes a couple other species
that are added in for histidine
metabolism
but if you look at this you'll see it's
exactly what i just
drawn where you get these key species
where
n5-methyl
thf is effectively
carrying a methyl group so one carbon
methyl donor
n5n10 methylene
thf is carrying the
formaldehyde and
n10 formal
thf is carrying
the formate group um to donate
as a one carbon unit this will be the
donor
ultimately for things like choline
synthesis
formaldehyde and n5n10 methylene and
formal thf will be important in
nucleic acid synthesis and we'll see
that next time
and so now if we go back to our shmt
reaction i can show you how these things
really work and so here's
a
thf molecule and so
here is the
intermediate in serine glycine
conversion
bound to
pyridoxal phosphate
etc and
that will release glycine
and eventually plp so glycine and plp
can be generated from that and what ends
up
here on the folate
is
which is a n5 n10
methylene thf okay
and if i take this and i oxidize it
okay can take the aldehyde
to the acid so oxidation nad plus is
reduced to nadh
now i get an n10 formal
thf and if instead
i reduce it
so electrons from nadph go to nadp
plus so nadph gets oxidized electrons go
there
and then i get an n5 methyl
thf this gives me
a donor of methyl groups this gives me a
donor
of formal groups
all right very last thing i want to talk
about today
is we'll talk a lot about how we use
the more oxidized species
next time to generate nucleotides but i
want to say a few words about how
these methyl groups are used to
be involved in methylation reactions
things like
choline synthesis shown up there um
but also not just choline synthesis
also can be used for reactions
involved in say epigenetics and so
for those of you who will never think
about biochemistry again after taking
this class
but we'll take um think about genetics
you'll certainly know the gene
expression is controlled by methylation
of dna and histones and things like that
those methyl groups have to come from
somewhere and they come
ultimately from these methylation
reactions the serine
um there now i don't have time to go
through
all of one carbon metabolism this gets
very complex
but it turns out the one carbon donor
for most methylation reactions isn't
n5-methyl thf even though that's where
the methyl group comes from
it's actually this molecule
so this here is the amino acid
methionine
and if i put it here onto an adenine
what i end up with is this molecule
called
s adenosial
methionine
or sam
this methyl group on sam is very labile
and so
it is the universal methyl donor
to be used in methylation reactions
choline synthesis
epigenetic you know methylation of dna
or histones whatever
and if you transfer that methyl group
off you're left with
this non-proteinogenic
amino acid
that's called homocysteine and that
homocysteine
is here
onto an adenine to make s adenosil
homocysteine
which is abbreviated sah or
saw saw picks up
needs to regenerate sam methyl group has
to come from somewhere
this comes from n5-methyl
thf okay of course
generates thf and then thf can pick up
another methyl group
ultimately from serine to glycine
conversion and reduction
with nadph to make n5 methyl thf
i show here on the slide here's just
a picture of one carbon metabolism that
i took from a review article
and so here's sam metabolism
lots and lots of complicated reactions
there linked to cysteine metabolism and
polyamine metabolism
obviously don't have time to get into
this but i want you to appreciate that
this happens where salmon saw come from
how they're involved in one carbon
metabolism because this will come up
again
in your future endeavors if you do
something with biology
all right final topic next time is
nucleic acid metabolism
and then we will have covered all of the
basics of
metabolism thanks
you